About the Joe Rogan experience.
If the aliens came to you and said,
rich,
yeah,
we're going to give you this technology,
whatever it is probably gonna be yes.
Can't tell anyone else.
Yeah.
Would you be willing to what technology?
What if the government brings you to area 51 like Bob Ozar and they bring you
down into the base.
Yeah and they show you an alien spacecraft and they go,
we're going to let you examine this.
We know that you'd love to tinker and back engineer things but you can't tell
anybody are you in?
I'll do it in a heartbeat.
The hell not because you have a,
you owe us the rest of the human race.
Like these fucking assholes and the government,
they're going to keep you telling us the truth.
Don't you think it would affect the whole world if we knew now,
honestly,
I probably tell you on anyways cause the fact that they called the Tesla guy to
go down there,
you of course you're going to rat them out.
Well that's who I would call if I was the government.
I wouldn't call some respectable scientist from Stanford cause that guy,
I would call some dude who would be like easily discredited.
So the guy who may be like a little little fudgy with science reports and
vicious and maybe plagiarize a little bit in college,
but he knows his shit.
That's me.
Yeah.
But no,
I would,
I would go with some guy who's,
um,
w w what does that autodidactic is that the word someone learns themselves?
Is that what the word is?
There's a lot,
right?
Is that the word?
There's a lot of geniuses out there that just don't have the credentials.
Very smart people.
And just auto didactic.
The didactic.
Yeah.
Take that guy,
take that guy.
What do you do that now?
I tell everybody why a hundred percent why would you,
why do you trust those assholes?
You know,
owe anyone anything.
Cause I would,
I would want everyone to know,
well,
what are they gonna do with it?
They have to live with myself.
Really.
100% yeah.
If the government wants to tell me some secrets,
let me tell you something.
I'll tell everybody.
Yeah.
Would you say that first?
I would definitely tell them.
I'm telling everybody realizes they don't show it to me freely.
Yeah,
I would say don't show it to me that's not progressing the human race forward
because there's always the goal is for you to see it and confirm it.
Right.
You want to see a converter and tell everyone,
you just be willing to say,
I don't want to die and I don't want them to kill me.
So I would say,
listen,
if you show me how you for that,
maybe people have died already and we don't know.
It's deep maybe bro.
Yeah,
look into it.
I'm like,
I don't know.
It would be a thing where I would,
in all honesty,
it depends on what stage of my life.
If I was 30 years old and they said,
I'm going to show you this,
but you can't show anybody,
are you willing?
I'd be like,
yeah,
sure,
show me,
but at 50 I'd be like,
no,
no.
I'm not making any deals.
I don't want to make a deal.
Or You tell me that.
I can't tell anybody about,
I mean it's one thing if it's a business thing,
like,
hey,
we're going to,
Apple's going to show you the new iPhone.
Don't tell anybody.
Oh,
for sure.
I won't tell anybody.
Right,
fine,
but this is something what can affect the human race?
How would Ald,
how would the confirmation of aliens affect the human race?
You think?
Well,
yes,
there are aliens now what we're going to do.
Realistically,
you would have to have confirmation that was undeniable and your own eye
witness.
That's not good enough.
Just think you're crazy.
They'll shoot you anyways.
Exactly.
They'll just think you're a fool and they'll just make you look like a dunce and
no one.
It would actually probably help their cause,
right,
because no one would ever believe you and no one would take alien seriously
after that,
which is one of the arguments for like what they actually did with project blue
book.
Like there was a guy named Phillip Corso and Jay Allen Hynek was the guy who was
running project blue book.
One of the things that they famously said after it was over that they were,
they would just try to debunk things and make these things look foolish and then
anything they found that they couldn't explain,
they just tucked away,
but the things that they could explain,
even if the,
the,
the explanation didn't jive.
He came up with an explanation just to make people realize that aliens were
bullshit,
but he,
through the course of project blue book studying now,
now you have to ask your question.
This question here.
Through the end of it,
he decided that aliens were real and that we had been contacted.
Yeah.
However,
you always have to question whether someone,
everything is doing that because this is a new avenue for them to make money.
Yeah.
Is this a new stream of revenue?
I'm going to do the lecture circuit.
I'm going to write books.
I mean if you're a guy where for project blue book and then they shut project
blue book down,
you don't have any more money.
Yeah.
You're broken and you decide,
well,
I don't want work for the government anymore.
You know what I want to do?
I'm going to write stories about Ufo and start a podcast.
Lock these assholes,
right?
I mean,
Jay Allen Hynek died along time ago,
I believe,
right?
Google Jay Allen Hynek project blue book have photos.
All right.
I'm pretty sure there's interviews where after he said he is sure after all of
his time studying that there is and has been some contact with extra
terrestrials.
What do you think?
I don't,
I don't know.
See mean me personally,
I have zero experience.
Right.
All right,
well,
so someone might,
what do you got?
We laughing at?
Ah,
man,
I don't want to talk about it yet.
You don't want to talk about and talk about it yet.
Stuff I've been looking into.
Go ahead about this topic that this guy worked at,
that company I've been told and told you about in,
in Columbus,
Ohio.
He also was a teacher of physics and astronomy at Ohio state in 1936.
Dawn,
dawn,
dawn.
So you think there's some real shit going down.
Maybe you think some real shit's going down.
I know about all the alien technologies are,
uh,
actually like what beings or aliens or something.
There's something going on and it has to do with that company and it has to do
with everything you're talking about and project blue book.
I don't know what it is.
That's very vague.
I know
something's going on guys.
I can't cause it's it,
to me,
it doesn't seem fair to just go with the big conspiracy,
but there are facts that you can look up and find.
So once you get to the bottom of the investigation that you'll have a report for
a yeah,
we'll talk to you.
I'll talk.
I'm not,
I'm not ready to,
just a little too crazy right now.
I want to leave some of the craziest stuff out.
Yeah.
It's one of those subjects that inherently starts looking crazy until alien show
up.
Right there was like that.
What was that movie?
What was the,
the recent movie with the,
the,
where they spoke in like smoke.
Oh.
Oh God.
Um,
was that big arrival arrival.
If something like that shows up,
then all of a sudden our perceptions completely changed.
It's like,
oh wait,
undeniable.
There's like some giant Los Angeles size thing floating over the continental us.
We'd be like,
okay,
all right.
So it has the thing.
So why would you say,
if we,
let's just say we had a microscope,
right?
Periscope,
whatever the,
whatever you call it,
to look in the space.
Really Fullscope telescope.
Periscope it.
If I wasn't a submarine,
so,
and we see an e an alien,
you know,
colony.
Yeah.
I'm like Mars,
what would we do?
Would study it.
Yeah.
We tried to communicate with it,
but would that be a good move?
Like what if they came over to us and they'll go,
oh,
look at these fucking dumb chimps.
Do they think these,
do they,
you think that any foreign or alien species,
we think we're idiots.
100% of really think we're idiots.
Yeah.
If they're advanced to the point where they've gotten control of their emotions
and anger.
Right.
Let me just think about how much tribal warfare goes on still in America,
uh,
in the world.
You know how much,
how much warfare is taking place,
how many people are dying,
how many innocent people are dying,
who drones,
all that kind of stuff,
right?
They'd be aware of all that they'd be aware of are polluting of the environment
they'd be aware of,
are depleting the ocean of it's fish and it's just pulling in giant nets filled
with fish and feed him.
What the fuck are you people doing?
They'd be looking at coal plants and the president of United States the greatest
superpower of the world's ever known,
saying things like clean coal,
like clean coal.
What do you,
what do you think?
Okay,
so someone comes to visit us,
right?
What's the dumbest thing that they're going to notice?
The first you can say,
Oh wow,
this is the dumbest thing you've ever said.
What's the number one thing you visit our planet?
The number one dumbest thing they're going to see him till I think the
pollutions,
the number one dumbest,
like you guys are shitting in the environment that you need to sustain you all
right?
You're,
you're,
and you're doing this in,
it's not like you don't have the resources to fix that infinite money.
Yeah,
and we have incredible amounts of money,
but yet the money's not going towards that.
Massive resources should be going to removing carbon from the atmosphere.
Removing particulates from the atmosphere.
Yeah.
Like brake dust and all the shit that's in these cities and these cars are
constantly slamming on their brakes.
That dusty,
you have to clean off your wheels.
That shit's everywhere,
right.
Then your lungs,
baby,
it's fucking everywhere.
Yeah,
and takes years off people's lives.
It absolutely does.
They would look at all that.
They would go,
go,
why aren't they looking at that?
Like,
why aren't they,
why don't they have some sort of system in place to mitigate all the problems
I've created in terms of like,
oh,
I mean,
they got rid of plastic straws,
right?
Yeah.
Keep,
keep the caps though.
Keep the bottle to find,
keep tabs that you pull off of things.
Keep plastic wrap.
Everything's plastic.
I think of those new disintegrating straws,
by the way.
Ridiculous.
It's like I want to keep around.
What a stainless steel we'll should,
but you have to clean it though.
So that same thing you can call stab somebody.
If somebody attacks you can get one with a sharp,
Sharp,
pointy end.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'm sorry that I stabbed this feral punch a hole through them.
Like that walking dead crossbow.
Yeah.
I think,
um,
that's the big one that we would,
that they would get,
they would go,
wow,
these people are crazy.
The other thing they would say is the nuclear power thing.
Like when you find out things like the Fukushima plant,
they didn't have,
uh,
any sort of backup plan to shut the hell up.
Shut it down.
Yeah.
Like you don't know what happens if your generator goes out.
Oh,
well we're fucked.
No,
it's nothing really clear.
Meltdown.
Everything dies forever.
Yeah.
They didn't plan on that like that.
The fact that we,
they built these plants and they have no idea how to shut them off.
Like that's crazy.
Yeah.
The aliens would probably like,
these people are their fucking mind.
They're smart enough to figure out how to harness nuclear power,
but what they use it for is to generate steam.
Yeah.
Constant.
And it,
and it has to stay on forever.
That's why they put him near the oceans.
Like these cats are assholes.